las protestas estaban convocadas desde
hace varios días pero como nos decía uno
de los tantos participantes de estas
protestas hoy enteran es que no hay
coordinación todos de ellos salían a las
calles sin saber realmente Cuántas
personas habían iban a participar y así
sucedió muchos de ellos llegan a
diferentes sectores de la ciudad y van
agrupándose en la medida que esas
fuerzas de seguridad lo permiten
Generalmente no es posible debido a la
fuerza y esto también lleva a muchas
veces a grandes enfrentamientos como
vimos por ejemplo hoy en ese gran bazar
de Teherán también el más importante de
Irán donde se ven imágenes en videos de
cómo queman una estación de policía
después de enfrentamientos y también
veíamos algunos otros bazares que
estaban en huelga en el día de hoy pero
tal vez lo que más ha llamado la
atención hoy fue la visita que hizo el
presidente Ibrahim raizzi a la
universidad al Sáhara en Teherán es una
universidad de mujeres con tendencia
religio y allí se reunía con un grupo de
estudiantes todas ellas muy de negro muy
tradicionales como muy cercanas a esa
imagen de las mujeres que apoyan al
gobierno y él decía Pues que nadie que
los enemigos de Irán no iban a triunfar
pero mientras tanto afuera de la
universidad en el campus otras niñas
gritaban al presidente eslóganes en su
contra en contra del gobierno y le
pedían que se perdiera esto también
llegaban un momento cuando hubo
protestas en muchas ciudades del país en
mashup la segunda ciudad del país se ve
como en un vídeo una mujer Es atacada
con un disparo de las autoridades allí
hubo grandes protestas en el día de hoy
también en San Andrés la gran capital
curda en Irán donde hay escenas bastante
violentas Y al menos una persona habría
muerto